hey what's up guys My Name Is AO and
welcome to episode 20 of the Sparky game
engine Series so this episode is going
to be the optimization SL main episode
basically every 10 episodes we basically
do like a a code review of the last 10
episodes and we talk about what could be
optimized what could be improved what
could be refactored to be a bit more
usable and just any kind of Maintenance
that needs to be done stuff that I've
missed in previous episodes and I go
through all of the GitHub issues and
make sure that they're all resolved okay
so that is the plan for today so last
time 19 we basically did font rendering
and you can see we get this brilliant
font rendering going on and everything
is pretty good we've actually got some
kind of openl here 1281 which I think is
invalid value so or something like that
in in um something to do with that um so
we might have to take a look at that if
we have time but that's not really I'm
not even sure what that's coming from we
can probably track that down pretty
quickly what we will do eventually is
probably wrap all of open jael's calls
in some kind of inline debug method that
will actually
um yeah in fact for debug builds we can
just wrap it in a method that will also
spit out debug information about every
single open G call that's something that
will take ages to implement so we we'll
kind of we won't do it before this LOM
Dale but we'll probably do before next
one anyway um let's begin
so uh I'm just going to go to GitHub
right now and pull up all of the issues
so on the GitHub spark your repository
of course which has at
get.com Spar key um we have all of these
issues so under the issues section
there's also pull requests which I'll
I'll handle as well but we'll begin with
the issues I've actually closed a few of
them I shouldn't have I want to close
them on stream because then I can see
what needs to be addressed and what
doesn't so in the closed I think I yes
those two I did last episode These two I
did yeah so change glfw window size call
back and I said um it'll be changed in
episode 20
so um inside window and it you call gfw
set window size call back to use G vport
in the call back G top says do not pass
the window size to CH viewport or yeah
is in screen coordinates not pixels use
the frame buffer size which is in pixels
and then there's a pull request which we
might as well take a look
at um where's the
code okay so yes it basically just does
that okay so it's just changing it to
set frame buffer size call back we might
as well do that since it's the correct
thing to do so in
window h i really I I'm going to install
some kind of visual assist or something
uh for next episode I'm getting tired of
having to look for things manually
instead of just finding them um but okay
so
Set
uh frame bu a size callback I'll
probably still leave it as window resize
though
because that is the window
resizing um and I don't think like the
frame barer is tied to the window for
Sparky anyway so I mean that still works
okay cool I'll still leave everything
else the same though um one thing I
should mention uh is if we go to our
shaders and we
reenable
lighting I like how
it I like how it affects the text as
well but um if we
uh um yeah if we look at this for
example um you can see that
uh what was I going to mention I totally
forgot someone I was looking at the chat
someone distracted me now I forgot what
I was going to mention um there was a
pro oh yes Mouse coordinates so if I
make the this full screen you can see
the mouse coordinates aren't really
that's our fault though because they are
it's just that the way that we've set up
our projection is that um it's a yeah
it's not not the best idea so get width
and height right return M width and when
M height does that do we do that for the
Callback where's the window SI callback
oh it's not even here okay we need to
refactor the window size
callback which window resize which is
here to actually set the wi height at
the appropriate window so it needs to be
um the same thing that we that we've
done here so window resize all we need
to do to fix that I think we've got it
up here as well yes so I'm going to get
rid of window resize up here I'm going
to make it a member of the window class
just like these guys are so
friend friend static void window resize
and it takes in that and a width and a
height I
believe okay so now it's now it's good
um what we can do now is the same way
that
we did that all of that stuff we can
just
set
um so we can just use
this and then set
wi do uh M width equal to
width and then that equal to
height that's important to do so so if
we now take a look at this um and we
print out say the width and height of
the window so window. getet
width window. getet
height then it should adjust to our
resizing and as you can see
does
okay okay so that's that fixed um yeah
cool so to fix the light if we really
wanted to in our test thing we just need
to instead of dividing it by 960 we
should divide it by window. get
width and similarly with
540 we get height and then of course the
other values that we have such as 18 9
and 32 depending on our actual
projection
Matrix so but that should fix it cuz the
projection Matrix still stays says the
same so now you can see the light works
in full screen follows our Mouse
properly fantastic okay so now that
we've done that um we can close that
issue I think so that was a pull request
as well so let's just close the pull
request so update when was that it yes
so fixed in episode 20
closeing
comment okay
um now over
here
um we
will Okay so we've done that now right
I've already closed that okay and then
group needs a Destructor I also said
group group short does need a Destructor
we'll upcoming episodes so um let's go
to group
oh another thing we should do is
organize this properly so so it matches
this so in fact I might just do that now
before we do the group stuff so we have
Source Graphics which has all of our
stuff and that's like it I don't think
we've got okay Graphics input mouth
shaders okay so we'll make under header
files we'll make
graphics this stuff is just for visual
Studio by the way input I don't think
input has anything in it we can just
delete
that uh
input um
maths what else did we have shaders
utils a shaders weren't actually part of
okay we won't have shaders in there um
shaders yous
okay oh there's one more thing I wanted
to do when utils by the way okay so in
fact I might just make this a bit bigger
for now I'll just make it bigger like
this I won't bother putting it somewhere
else just so you guys can see a bit
better um so into so batch render
buffer group index buffer label not the
math stuff
renderable uh Shader that that that that
that and that goes into Graphics now
this doesn't change anything on disk by
the way this is just inside Visual
Studio inside this thing um okay and
then file utils image load and timer
goes into utils and then the rest should
be maths right yes okay cool so we've
sorted this out now that was pretty easy
inside Graphics I had something called
buffers and then layers I
think so inside buffers we'll put all of
the buffer stuff um and the vertex array
as well why is that not
here guess it's not included in the
project for some ridiculous reason okay
and then the other thing is this only
shows us far as that in the project so
it's better to use than the other thing
okay um so
vertex uh
array that's still not here
what buffers vertex radar H that's in
our
project why is it not here wait I'm
looking at
Graphics uh pop that into buffers and
we'll put a buffer into there and index
buffer as well
all right and then layers we'll just put
our
layer and we're not actually our tire
layer of course yeah okay good
everything else is pretty good um oh
stuff like groups
and labels and whatnot I think I'll
labels are rendera bles though so I
might make another folder called rendera
bles so I'll put stuff like so yeah I'm
just I'm just going to sort this out
this is this is what the maintenance
episode are about just stuff that isn't
really we're not adding new features
we're just sorting out the existing ones
so uh that stuff renderable itself and
uh label as well so label should go into
there all right and then we have
renderers and then shaders and just a
bunch of stuff here so I think that's
probably good enough for now Okay so
we've sorted this out quite a bit now we
have to duplicate that same setup um
over here in source files so we want to
have
Graphics um what's the new oh there's no
anyway Graphics uh maths and
utils some of these are heter only as
well so we'll just grab the math stuff
for now pop them into not utils
maths um do we have so timer was header
most of the utils are header only aren't
they we might even need that we'll see
so label layer shade uh yep shaded
pretty much everything will go
into Graphics we've done mostly Graphics
work that will go into Graphics buffer
needs to go into Graphics group needs to
everything goes into Graphics yes we
don't have any utils utils are header
only okay um so
now
um I'm going
to
uh sort this out so inside what do we
have so we had inside yeah inside this
we had
buffers and
layers and rendera
bles that's not correctly spelled render
erables uh Ren rendera bles um yeah so
inside so buffer and index buffer and
vertex array goes into buffers
layers group and then layer and then
title layer so group title layer and
layer and the rest well not the rest but
label uh renderable we don't have
renderable so label Sprite static Sprite
go into rendera bles and that's it yeah
okay great so this is now really nicely
fixed up and you can see that something
like main isn't even part of the thing
it's out here okay now we should make so
we've got um header file source files we
can make a uh sorry
inside can't we make a uh yes we'll make
a new filter called shaders just like
that and that'll have our shaders inside
it like that okay so basic frag invert
will it basically it will if they will
be embedded into our actual source code
as a string eventually okay this is just
easier for now so they'll be our default
shaders and we'll probably make them be
a bit more errorful than this okay we
might have a default shad and then we
might have something like an error
Shader or something like that so
basically
um if something goes wrong and we don't
have a Shader or something isn't
correctly set whatever we can just sort
of like if I don't know we don't if the
like for example if the Shader doesn't
compile we can still let our game run
but it will show like an error Shader
which might have the word error written
or probably flash different colors or
something like that cool so that's
looking pretty good when we're now
organized so this the issue that I
wanted to fix was um well there were a
few things so inside um inside our utils
so this will be in header files and then
let me
just bring that back up here um inside
header files we've had uh
inails so one thing I want to mention in
file details oh there was an issue about
this so I should probably go to that
issue oh group Destructor We'll add that
in a second we'll fix this small issue
first though um someone mentioned
that H this was a p
request yeah someone mentioned that it
would be faster um using C++ style
things well he didn't actually say it
would be faster but he said we should
use that so instead of using file use
this um I did a I did quite a few tests
because this is a little bit yeah I I
did a few tests it's it's not really
faster it's it is faster for really
large files and I'm talking about like
over 1 Megabyte so if we're reading um
and that's not non-binary files by the
way text files over 1 Megabyte which I
don't think we'll ever have um but my
point is for the smaller files it was
this was much faster much faster so I
think I'm just going to stick with this
method overall they perform about the
same for large files I'm not saying this
is so much faster for large files this
is about the same as this for large
files for small files this is faster so
it's really not um there's no point in
us actually doing that so we're just
going to keep using normal files I
should probably say something
like addressed in episode
20 so we'll keep
using using
file
I don't know about binary files
um yeah no I I yeah I legitimately
tested um I legitimately tested it for
like a variety of samples in fact I'll
pull up the project I used to test it in
a minute maybe I don't know probably
probably not not that thingy okay so
unfortunately the stream cut out which
means my recording stopped which is why
there was some pause or jump that
happens from time to time anyway I was
talking about files and whatnot um so
yeah so we'll keep using file
for file right reading because it's
generally
faster yeah but I
um okay but yeah I I did do tests and it
was
surprisingly uh the s+ plus method was a
little bit faster in like again files
that are like 2 megabytes plus
so um anyway overall though it was
slower okay so um group Destructor yeah
okay so what I wanted to do here is
currently we have a class in this I
don't know why I did that we shouldn't
have that it should just be a procedural
method especially since I'm using the
procedural like convention um for names
here well my convention for names here
so we'll just do that um if we leave it
as static it'll be fine if we remove
static it might cause problems but if we
um yeah so I'll show you what I mean so
if we build this we're in release mode
Let's just build an debug um I'll wait
for this might as well okay let's build
it in
debug okay we'll fix these problems
quickly okay so we might get these
things but if we um what are these
exactly yeah we'll we might get multiple
definitions and whatnot but if we mark
them as
static because if we yeah you you'll see
what I mean if Mark if we mark it a
static we shouldn't get any problems
because it if we don't mark them a
static it will probably do the same
it'll do the same thing as we did in um
as it did in free type when free type
included C++ files so or rather C files
so yeah Market is static and you should
be good to go anyway we fixed that now
now we use procedural style for reading
files which is good we don't need a
class that um not that class would
necessarily be too much overhead I don't
think
but
um but yeah this this will be better
Okay cool so we fixed that now the group
Destructor thing let's let's address
that so inside group so what the concern
is and this is totally valid obviously
um is we've got a bunch of renderable
pointers here but we never delete them
which means that if we do a scenario
such as this where we add a bunch of
stuff like fps to a group FPS actually
never gets destroyed okay um
ever because like the layer again
doesn't know about the group The group's
just just another renderable so the
group will call sorry the lay the layer
will call group's Destructor but the
destructor for group does nothing so it
should delete its rendera bles so if I
make a group like
this and then I sorry if I make the
aductor like this and then I find the
um
freaking I need to install some tools to
make this stuff easier because it's
annoying looking for files now that
we've got more than a
few um okay
so this will just go through all of our
rendera
bles that's definitely not a pointer
that's what the were called right that's
those are our ones yes they are and we
will delete
them okay fantastic
cool okay so that's fixed let's make
sure that still builds and runs properly
not sure why it wouldn't okay good
great best okay so that's fixed all
right good so there's so many issues so
now that they're closed uh we we were
actually going through the closed ones
now we need to go through the open ones
cuz there's a lot so input handling
should be we'll start at the beginning
of the end well the thingy anyway um
input handling should be mindful of the
keys previous state so the engine only
shows us the current state of a key on a
given frame yeah so that is on this
Frame yeah key all this stuff
here I remember reading this like a week
ago we need a housekeeping bull to
ensure our weapon fires on only the
first time a frame yes TS to do for
every
case you compare the previous car States
um
yes okay button pressed another yeah so
oh this this is just for key typing
right we could just have is key
typed I think that's what he's getting
at because that would be kind kind of
easy but the problem is
um
yeah it wouldn't work for multiple
things until it's
released that's a complex issue
actually because the problem is unless
we update it once
per h
yeah but see there's stuff like repeat
or I imagining that I remember reading
yeah so key held and whatnot
so what we could do is yeah so the
problem here is pretty simple well it's
actually not but I'm going to try and
simplify
it so what we could what the problem is
this and this is how I'm imagining we
need some kind of yeah so that is a
terrible K I need to get a better
graphics tablet or something that can
actually let me ride instead of this
10-year-old thing key uh so key typed so
this is the situation right what if we
only want to do something one so if I
press a key down let's just say I press
the K key down just to be LOLs um I want
to trigger an event that says that the
key is pressed but the second Loop so
the second update of the input if the
key is still down I basically want to
return something like false instead of
true so this might be like true cuz the
key is down so the key is typed but then
the next frame it'll be false until the
key gets released again and then pressed
again and then so it's only true for the
first time now this is great and this is
really easy to do for example we could
store the state of the key in an array
of sorts this is one example an
implementation we could store the state
in an array and then say that if the
state is still in the array for for the
key then return false if it's not there
return true so for the first time we'd
add it to the aray to the array um to
the array it would return true but then
the next time it' be like oh it's
already in the array I'll return false
and then upon release we'll clear the
array or sorry clear just get rid of
that key from the array so which key we
released that is an acceptable solution
but the problem is since since these
things are static if you have two
classes such as for example K might do
multiple things right so or the mouse
button so you might want the mouse
button to
fire this is one example I can't think
of a better one right now but you want
if like upon clicking so it works the
same with mouse buttons obviously once
you click once you don't want to if it's
like keepy PR if it's like button
pressed versus um versus button clicked
right click should only return once and
then upon release and then pressing
again it will return true and then the
next time it will return false you guys
kind of get what I mean right so click
um when we click
um uh we want to fire right only and
then we'll have to release the mouse and
click again to fire again for example
and then we also want to handle a menu
click for example what am I doing so if
we click on a particular thing in the
menu um
that is okay if we click on a particular
thing in the menu we also want that to
register once but the problem is if in
our game this comes before this one the
clicker will return true here and false
here even though we've clicked so this
becomes a complex problem
because it's almost like we want that
particular method to return true but
then kind of stop returning things so
it's yeah it's a bit
annoying
um yeah so one other way of doing it
instead of handling it on the events of
key press and key release is you could
do something like um once per
frame and this is the this is the simple
way of doing it this is the kind of the
full
foolproof way of doing it
right you could um once per frame so for
example on input. update I think I think
we got that so maybe on window do
update yeah on window. update we might
call something like and these W's are
just looking so bad anyway window.
update we might want to basically grab a
snapshot of the current key states of
everything of all the keys so like
what's down what's up you just you know
grab like the entire Key State
essentially right and then the window
will store that and then the next time
it comes we like okay well this is also
down for example um and we can grab the
copy we can compare it and we can
say
um like essentially if we even store two
of these so A and
B uh we can be like well was it down in
a as well like if if we're doing key
typed we can be like so this is a
certain key it's down here and it's also
down here so where like key typed in
this case will always return true
because it's down but in this case it'll
return false because it will look at the
previous one and it'll be like oh that
key was also down I can't return false
twice so this will work for I'm probably
doing a terrible job of explaining this
but um cuz it is kind of hard to explain
but uh basically it'll look at its
previous one and then if you release a
key obviously it'll clear that so that
might be black and then in this case
it'll look at the previous one oh it's
false and this is true so we'll return
true we could do that okay in fact let's
have a go at implementing that right
now so inside input uh we don't have
inputs so inside
window I hate this um so there's window
H and whatnot luckily we had we had them
open but inside here um let's go ahead
and uh make something like a bull m key
state which will be something like Max
Keys performance- wise this probably
isn't going to be be the fastest things
and we'll just do something like two so
this is going to be a two um I should
have done that the other way
around so we're we're holding two key
States
um for all all our keys essentially I
guess this could act as a current Key
State though so we probably don't need
to store this um we could probably just
store that one um we'll do the same with
mouse buttons let's make it work with
the keys first so M Key State um so if
we go
into
window we kind of in update which is
here we want to read the key States so
let's go through all of
them and we'll just go ahead and say m
key State I equals
m keys I so that'll that'll grab the
that'll G that'll grab the
um that will grab the okay so yeah we'll
this is the optimization episode so
we'll optimize this for Loop in a minute
as well but um M Key State I equals MK I
so we're basically going to copy all of
the keys here but before we do that we
should check the previous statee now one
thing I should mention is we do need to
instantiate
this um so the same way that we did this
we can just add in M keys I equals
false okay
so um before we copy them here we want
to basically go through them kind of
like what we do here so I might actually
copy this and we want to see um in our
type thing what's true and what's not
so so let's break this down into this if
we're going through this we want to
basically
say
if
mkss
uh at
I
equals apparently I yes I'm an idiot
State
um so if this equals m key State
I sorry if it doesn't um I should say
this if it's true
um
I don't know we might optimize this in a
minute I actually I don't know what I'm
doing we'll figure it out so if the keys
is true and that is also true we can
probably add it to some kind
of so we'll return true on the next tick
so let's set this up we'll have a um so
we've now right now we've got is key
pressed let's just do is key typed so
it's going to be quite special and
you'll see so is key typed if we go into
his is key
pressed here it is log this
whatever is key typed this is
um this will basically instead of
looking at M Keys it will look at some
kind of
like we can have key typed okay so we'll
make a third one and we we might not
need it but this is going to be the
simplest way to do this now and we might
optimize it I love how it this in the
optimization episode cuz this is also
the maintenance episode though so yeah
but m key types Max Keys um so this will
be our key okay so yes so in here we
want to sorry my internet uh failed
again which meant recording cut which is
why there was that pause thing anyway m
key typed IAL
false
so oh this is this is getting probably
more complicated than it needs to be oh
um
so uh we will so that's the previous
frames and this is the current frames so
if it's pressed we need to say if that
is also
pressed
um oh fre
okay so what I'm trying to say
is
m key typed is going to equal m key
State sorry is going to equal m keys I
and
not M Key State I okay that is how this
will work so
um yeah so there we go that that should
work maybe and then we do this copy
thing we'll use M Copy in a minute
because it's much faster but I thought
I'd show you the practical way of doing
it as well so that you can make more
it'll make more sense I don't know if
this will work let's just try
so uh we'll just go see
out um and then we'll just
say
um is uh window do is key typed GF W
key K cuz that was our example
key
um and then we'll just say something
like yeah we'll just we'll print
that so
zero a better way of doing it would be
probably printing this
so we'll print
K okay see so when I press it it's doing
that but if I hold it down it doesn't do
it okay now the useful thing about this
is that we can do this multiple times
per frame so if I do it again and I'm
like totally works this will be
embarrassing if it doesn't but it will
um you can see it
like accept both those events see that's
important so if we just did the way I
described there it wouldn't work okay
let's optimize this a little bit since
it is the optimization episode and we'll
also do the same thing for Mouse buttons
actually let's quickly do the mouse
button thing first
um so Key State key typed so we need
both of those for Mouse
State and mouse
clicked so the memory over head on this
is not the best
but it's all right so max buttons we
don't have too many buttons anyway so
it's it's all good so out
here um we want
to Mouse State Mouse type
clicked and then over here
um same kind of deal
um except with mouse so Mouse
clicked Mouse State
equals Mouse
buttons so Mouse buttons and
not Mouse
State okay so and then there should be
Max buttons
obviously cool so now we got a few of
that stuff again we'll use well for this
stuff we won't but for this stuff we'll
use M Copy in a minute
um key typed yes so we'll do mouse
button pressed is mouse
button
clicked um
button and it is so m u Mouse
clicked
button Okay cool so back in here we will
add that
quickly there we go all right cool so
let's quickly just try that out that out
since we probably should
um window dot uh is mouse button clicked
J W button
one
or
left try out
twice great fantastic so uh now let's
optimize it a little bit by using M Copy
so for this case we can just use M Copy
which is much faster so a brief example
of why it's faster um basically M Copy
doesn't touch the CPU so the CPU doesn't
have to go through this and like it'll
add it to its case and what not it'll
flow through the CPU and add it you know
cach is an example of where it would add
it as well the CPU cache but if we just
use M Copy it's not going to it's going
to be much faster it's not going to
actually even touch the CPU so uh
basically something like this can be
turned into M Copy um so we have the
destination we have the source and we
have the size really important to note
this is in bytes this will copy bite by
bite it will not um copy say you're
copying integers it won't copy integers
by integer it'll copy them by bite so
for example M set Works kind of the same
it's got the exact same thing it's just
a setting so if you're trying to set a
bunch of integers to like two it won't
do that it'll set every single bite to
two not every single to do so that's one
thing to know that does do it bite by
bite M set will work with car with
unsigned chars or Char because they take
out one bite in C++ but anyway M Copy uh
so the source is or the the destination
first so the destination is Key
State the source is keys and we want to
copy basically the size of M keys and I
think this will work in fact we don't
have to do that we can just say Max keys
and what are they exactly they're
bulling so they're bite so if we really
want it to be cool we could
be well size of bull but the size of
bull is one
so that will also work cool so there's
our M Copy and that will be faster than
the other thing that I mentioned then
it'll be faster than this
right and we'll do the same thing for
this so Mouse State Mouse buttons and
Max
buttons Okay cool so that should work
the same way fortunately I got rid of
all of our testing code let's bring that
back real
quick and it's totally all right okay
good cool so there we go that's a really
small optimization we could also do the
same thing here I this doesn't matter
though because it happens in window
initialization it's not something that
happens real time every frame you could
change this to a mem set um again I'm
not going to bother because it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter if it's a few
CPU Cycles less because it's
um it happens on in on the construction
of the window which will happen once
like at the beginning of the game if
it's not real time if it's not in the
random if it's not in the update of the
random method and inside this game Loop
we don't care about optimization
basically to an extent obviously if
something takes 10 seconds versus one
it's a problem but those are more or
less loading times rather than actual
frame rates Okay cool so we've done that
we can now check that
off
thank you for
opening an
issue okay so back to issues we are
going through this quite slowly um I
thought I closed you well I did I didn't
refresh the page
properly um
what oh that's not the same issue okay
failed to create gfw window
what oh I think this guy just didn't
copy
properly
yeah like as in yeah so quick note if
you are having trouble you're if you're
not like stealing code from this
repository and you're actually
um and you're actually
um copying down from the actual videos
and you're following the YouTube series
and basically doing your own version of
Sparky don't open issues here these are
for issues with the actual code in this
actual repository okay if you want help
or if you have something like if
something's not working you can just go
to the Cho Forum not
slf SL forums and um under Sparky engine
as you can see there's this great thing
called General so every so this is where
you post stuff that you copied down
wrong or something that doesn't work
okay okay posted in the forums GitHub
issues are for the code in the in the
GitHub repository right make sense
hopefully it does no inverse function
currently in Matt yeah so there's yeah
okay so a lot of people are like maybe
you should use glm instead of
um uh our own Mass we're making our own
Mass library for a few reasons a doesn't
probably doesn't need to be as
complicated as glm glm is pretty good it
even has stuff like um s and whatnot
it's it's a it's a good Library I I like
it but this is more or less an
educational uh series I'd rather have my
own math Library stuff like free type is
different than this um this stuff is not
too difficult this G so so glm is like
an open G maths header only Library
thing and this Library um uh yeah so
they explain it a little bit but I have
used glm before in fact I think
churncraft uses glm if you check out my
repository they'll be there it'll be
there um so I do like glm but since this
is Sparky we want to have our own Mass
and whatnot so we should um probably
have some kind of Matrix in inverting
thing it looks like um someone has
already done this
um and this will work yeah obviously
this will work for uh a lot of things
but so the other thing is ssse is a
probably a good thing for us to do SS
will not be you won't be able to compile
that into M scripton though so SSC would
only be for or desktop versions of
Sparky therefore it's not a priority we
will be doing s eventually because I do
want to cover that in videos and I also
want to um actually make the math and
Sparky faster four times faster up to
but um it's not going to be something
that we're going to handle as a priority
because again it won't be compatible
with everything it'll just be like a
desktop only kind of thing okay cool
anyway let's just steal this because
yeah it's probably correct
so return to
true I see what he's
doing he's doing it like C style or
something anyway um so inside um so if
you don't know about Matrix inverting
and what not you can cover that yourself
probably I've done I think I've done
enough math explanation inverting The
Matrix isn't like it's useful but again
it's not something that you will use
incredibly commonly like you will with
say translation or rotation so um
therefore I'm not going to spend too
much time on it therefore I'm just
stealing copy and pasting stuff
LS okay so
um should we
just yeah we'll just do it here so we'll
have
um so we won't be static is what I'm
saying it'll just be a normal thing so
we'll go um Matt 4 uh
invert
and then so where do we have that
beneath the multiplication
stuff
here okay so there's all the code um
we're going to have to go through this
so this is what's in I should probably
read how this works in Deb like
what that's the the yeah determinant and
then
that's yeah so M and then INF out so en
if is okay that's the source I'm
guessing could have labeled your
variables properly but okay that's the
output I'm guessing and then that's
the yeah okay that totally makes sense
so I'll call this
Temp and then I'll call
this
determinant and I do not spell that word
often is that correct yeah just had to
check um so we'll have
um and M is the source
right let's just find a
replace a few things can I find a
replace for a selection probably not
let's um there might be a way to do it
but I don't know what that is so
inside what was this oh this was this
our free type stuff um so inside here
I'll just do a find and replace uh not
in open folders just in this file um so
we replacing inv with uh what is it inv
was with
temp well not what I meant to do
replace 143 files no no no no no no this
file
ah open
files done and then m is the source
right yeah we're not touching that so
Source um so what what is it called just
it's just Matrix isn't it where's our
header oh
elements
I thought it was called
Matrix oh what
oh oh no that becomes bad because there
are a lot of M everywhere um let's see
how we
can do this we can probably ignore
temp well let's got a bracket next to it
everywhere so we can just do this
okay um and then yeah the other thing is
the determinist so we'll go back into
here
and restore that stuff okay cool so
there we go lot of code now uh
determinant is that
um we don't have to return FS
necessarily
and then so inval is
our output oh we
are yes so this will just be elements
equals temp time
determinants return this okay so there
we go that should work pretty well I'm
probably not going to test this code
just because what's so what what do we
use
I4 oh that's
hilarious
and
determinant is here so yeah they've
really done this C
style okay so there we go
um do we have a constant for that no we
don't excuse
me
we copy this code so I'm going to assume
it's right because it's got 51 up
votes okay good so anyway I'll assume
that's correct um good so that's that
done so we we're now um inverting The
Matrix I don't know
because because we don't need to that's
really the option like that's the big
thing we don't need
to
um I'll just say an inverse
function was added
in oh that was
bad okay
so an inverse function was added in
um uh episode 20 okay cool done
back to
issues uh optimization of band Yes I
replied to this um yesterday I think so
this person proposed that we um or h k
proposed that we basically go ahead and
C all of our vertex positions so inside
our batch renderer we
are yeah as you can see we're
recalculating everything so we're taking
we're creating a new V 3 we're adding
this size to the position and we're
doing all this maths inside the
submission so we're doing this every
frame right in fact more more than every
frame we're doing this for as many
surprices as we have so if we have got
50 57,000 or whatever we're doing 57,000
times right so he proposed that um this
is quite inefficient and what we should
do is um not calculate the vertex
positions every submit we should just
have something like a rectangle class um
and then then uh we should have a
rectangle inside this so that we would
basically only have to do this yeah
now uh there was it was also addressed
that we shouldn't be calculating colors
every frame as well and that's totally
totally legit now I responded with the
fact that
um that this actually won't be faster
due to CPU cing so what I'm saying is
um uh in it it totally and logically
seems like
cing um would be um something that you
uh sorry vertex position caching so not
calculating them seems like an
optimization it does because you're like
well yeah I guess you just have to read
existing memory you don't have to um you
have to recalculate these vertices so
many times per frame but actually it's
going to be slower because because what
happens is it just comes down to the
simple fact that reading memory from Ram
if it's not CPU CED reading Ram reading
memory reading physical memory is slower
than doing a few simple additions
okay it's as simple as that okay so
that's why in this case it's actually
going to be um slower to Cache this
because the CPU is going to have to read
more memory we've got 50,000 Sprites and
if you have an extra 52 I think it was
52 bytes of memory per Sprite the CPU is
going to have to read more memory to get
the same data that it could just
calculate and because of that it's going
to be slower because memory reads from
non-cash to memory is like 200 Cycles
but simple addition and what else are we
doing we're pushing I guess we're
pushing some things to the sack as well
by creating these that's like five
Cycles okay both the addition and that
so it's really quite small and there's
nothing to worry about so recalculating
is actually faster than caching in this
case this is legit though this
calculation is more than a few Cycles
okay there's a bunch of bit shifts and
yeah there's a lot of stuff that goes
there so what we want to do instead of
that is um we do want to cage these
colors especially because they don't
change very often so in order to support
that though we're going to have to do a
few things because what if you want to
change the color of your Sprite right so
inside um
renderable so rendera bles uh r 2D and
Sprite as well open a lot of things um
inside here we'll have something like so
we'll we've got the color here um we'll
have
a you know I'm actually going to change
this I'm going to refactor this because
I don't want to have ve four colors
anymore I've decided it's just we don't
we don't want to do that we'll have an
INT I I always I prefer unsigned in
colors to V fours
anyway so if you guys have have a
problem with that you can probably well
no no aan you will not have a problem
with this because you can you'll it'll
just do a conversion if you decide to do
that so I'll show you what I mean in a
minute okay cool so what we'll have is
we'll have a for the first time ever
we'll have a Setter so we'll have a um
sorry what am I doing we'll have a void
set color we'll have two of these one of
them will take an unsign INT
and this will Implement here oh we yeah
so I guess we can just do it here and
this will just simply set M color equal
to color and then we'll also have what
we had before which was the VC for again
in case some of you want to set it that
way I'm going to let you because of
course people people might prefer float
kind of um per Channel like um rgba
color is better than just one kind of
integer and sometimes it is totally
easier to do that by the
way rarely though
um so what this is going to do is it's
going to do that entire um conversion
that we had
here so this so only when we set color
will it do that though so it does all
this stuff separates the channels and
then it'll set um M color equal to that
okay cool makes sense so um
now all we need to do is now we don't
need to do this stuff and we really only
need to uh get the
unsigned
unsync the unsigned
int color we can make it I guess we'll
make it const here it doesn't really
matter because we're not going to modify
it
anyway but I guess if we were being
correct it would be more like this and
then we'll change color to C to sorry
we'll change C to color
and it looked like C was still a thing
yeah let's get rid of that okay cool so
we've optimized that now and then the
same thing will happen here you can see
we've got this VC 4 color that we take
in for
drawring I don't know why just takeing
an unsigned int color and everything
will be the
best so I like dealing with integers for
colors instead of for floats and to
mention it takes up a quarter of the
memory so there's really no reason to do
that but as I said I have left the
option to do that and if maybe in the
future when we're more or less we don't
have the ladom Dare coming up I might
make another method like this that
actually takes in a uh effect for if you
really want I think that that should be
provided okay so let's hop into the um
bat render header
file which is here
we'll change this to be an
unsigned in
color and then we'll have to change the
same thing in the
renderer okay so if we um okay so this
is going to cause problems in our main
class only hopefully I don't think it'll
cause any more errors apart
from okay no it'll cause errors here as
well that's right so unsigned int
color
uh here we can just set it to see that's
the beauty of it I I like this much more
um okay so
Sprite got this situation now let's just
rebuild
that okay um it's happening here as
well I'll static Sprite that shouldn't
even be a thing anymore I'll probably
get rid of static Sprite soon honestly
look at this I don't want to support
this um okay we'll leave it as this
we'll just oh that means we have to do
the
conversion this is the lazy way of
fixing
it you'll obviously ignore that actual
color but LS okay um labels so that's
yes unsigned
int just take me to the take me to
that refactoring for
days
okay um and now we're getting unresolve
symbols where what's this one
particularly uh looks like the VE for
it's a Constructor for sprite um
interestingly enough so where's our
Sprite um renderable 2D still takes in
no it
doesn't
um that's
weird we should probably also set uh
that means it'll probably
yeah it doesn't matter so what's up
here can I con okay what's the okay yeah
so now all the stuff is in here so this
is
white and we're wearing a 32bit color so
don't forget the alpha
channel uh This was um random on the red
channel oh that's going to be difficult
tocate
um
so we'll just
say we'll just do that um and then we'll
say equals uh alpan goes first right and
then it's BGR so
255 oh we can just do
so and then it's BGR isn't it so B what
was it
zero no that's blue so blue is full
that's zero and then
that's um
red
right yes that should work so we'll need
to shift
that um
eight okay so there we go
um that should
work yep okay let's just rebuild
it oh yes this so what was this it
was
so
3339 so we'll do
roughly
555 and nine
so I don't
know
DD doesn't really matter we're not
trying to match the color
exactly okay so if we launch this now
okay so that's correct we've lost
something
though does not look like the right
color but we've lost something um okay
so this this is correct the the red
channels what did we lose
um we lost the yeah we lost the textures
H we shouldn't
have hang on a
minute it probably had something to do
with
color not being white
it sure did okay so we need to set the
default color to white something that I
didn't do um I thought I did though well
no I guess what was I how was I doing
that before let's just quickly I think I
was setting it here wasn't I oh I forgot
FF so it had
yeah yay there we go okay cool
um great so there we go that's that
fixed uh let's get rid of the lighting
quickly so we can actually see it in
action properly uh where our
shaders
shaders looks pretty good yep
everything's correct okay um good so
that's that done so we've now that we're
not recalculating that at all um in fact
I can probably verify that by just
searching for something like that y okay
great so that's
done okay so back to our issues man
there are so many here a small
transformation stack
optimization wow that is not a good
idea so you're creating
a how does that even work
that's not correct because that returns
a reference and you're putting it to a
pointer that's not going to work first
of all I'll test it I might be wrong I
might have just forgotten my own API but
we'll see I'm pretty sure that won't
work uh where's that in that's in
um renderer
right now wait a minute
push back was it
push well he probably meant that but if
he meant that then wait what's
transformation back that's a PO right
yes see like doesn't even work because
that like the multiplication returns
that so that would be a reference and no
it's not and it's not going to make a
difference in
performance um the back operator isn't
that like slow it'll be yeah it'll be
totally okay um so I probably will write
a this that that's not going to
work because this doesn't have pointers
it's got copies of it that's a pointer
though
so
see he's always pushing the
transformation stack doesn't even have
pointers and he pushing a pointer into
there
so I I get what he's trying to say he's
trying to say that you can just you can
avoid using back operator by just doing
the calculation like this and applying
it to that but that's not going to
because it's
not keep in mind
that the
transformation step back Vector does
not hold
pointers uh please have not another
issue if you think
I am misunderstanding
you
okay
check 40 minutes ago hopefully you guys
don't start submitting all issues right
now otherwise this episode's never going
to end fragment Shad of
color okay looking at it with a fresh
fire okay so you can make this closed
okay so heard that the if is very costly
in the fragment Shader okay now you have
yeah okay you should have a static white
color as an unsigned in as
yeah
well um few things first of all
functionally it's going to behave very
differently because
um because we have tinting and textures
aren't always applied so there's no way
to get around this without branching the
second thing is
um these are basically free like okay
I'm not going to get into this too in
detail but um because the uh GPU has all
these parallel cores that act in unison
at the same time to do all this stuff um
we're actually Bound by something
called
um
Ro
GPU so again I'm not going to um get too
much into this but
basically maybe this will explain it
actually so SS and pixel Traders have
been
equal
um but basically to explain this in the
simple as simple terminology as possible
we're Bound by how fast the RS can
actually output pixels so what happens
is the first like unless we're doing
more than
say usually about I don't know let's
just say 30ish uh instructions in our
Shader that's basically free because
we're getting what's slowing us down is
this stuff not our actual Shader because
this can't output pixels fast enough
basically that's the problem so because
of that um because we're Bound by that
slowness um having an extra if Branch
like right now is going to be totally
free not to mention yeah so I we could
try and remove this but this is going to
be um it's not going to actually
increase the speed at all um it's going
to not change anything because it's not
doing anything like it's it's got
there's room for all this stuff to do
while we're waiting for all the DRS to
to get outputed so it's all good in the
hood
um
so
yes um that's the plan so if we um go
into um yes so I'll probably just I'll
probably write a more detailed response
being like you know props
image load free di data okay yeah this
is yeah so this is legit
um we created yeah so in our Textures in
our texture
stuff we
created uh this bite pixels and load
image of course made this but it never
freed it so we probably should free it
so
um what could we do to free
it so what was this is in free image
right so is does free image
have free image source code oh I really
is not on GitHub it's not is
it
um
C++ are you kidding
me where's the
actual
Repository
okay whatever let's just let's just try
and delete this and see what happens cuz
I I'm pretty sure free will just do
that oh maybe
not um debug session failed and I'm sure
it's
in
um yeah it'll probably be in
freaking okay
let's yeah so that's
wrong okay we'll use we'll find we'll
use it so we'll also get a dib from it
then so uh did he write about it CU I've
forgotten what it is so that's the
dib it's a bit annoying that we have to
handle this we could wrap it in a class
and
have
um we could wrap it in a class and get
it to return it that's so annoying
though
see and then we could call free image
that's here's what we'll do this is a
loading thing
anyway how do we delete oh I've
forgotten this let's quickly go into our
Libs and see how this
happens for image examples uh G
manager just Sublime Text
please okay
so free image unload that's
right so we'll unload our dib which will
probably get rid of the bites right will
it because this then in that case this
won't work so we'll
see yeah okay so what we will do is as
follows we're just going to copy that
data
so
um so before we free it we'll have a
so bite
pixels and then we'll make a new bite
result equals new bite now I have no
idea I think it's just width time
height
time
um times
thingy
um
free image
get bits
right what does that actually
return oh no that's that's not what I
meant
get what is it called oh I did it in um
main luckily
good this old code to the rescue which
we'll remove by the way so bits is uh no
so bit get B yeah bits per
pixel that's what I
wanted so with height times
yeah get bits per
pixel times bits / eight because it's in
bits not
btes I don't even know if this is going
to work because I don't know how it does
it so hopefully this will work but we'll
find out all those things everywhere so
many asteres all right um so text and
then we'll delete pixels
so let's see if this
works oh oh
no oh well no actually good that did
work well we don't know yet but I forgot
to actually copy them so m
copy um destination is result source is
pixels and of course the size
is
that
yeah
okay um and then we'll unload that dip
so let's take a look at
that so the difficult thing is working
out how much memory it actually takes up
yeah that looks good okay good so there
we go so we've now done it it will
unload it all you have to do later
though is just remember to delete the
pixels you get because of course they're
on the Heap and not you haven't deleted
them cool
um yes so there you go um um I think
that's done
so we're getting through these issues I
like
that okay fragment Shad of
color oh that's yeah that's right
Universal timer so de to quickly remove
the Windows of pen Andy for the timer
class only downfall as it requires yeah
that's fine uh
Chrono
yes that is that slower at all I'm not
sure I'll have to do some research into
this to figure out if it's there are any
downsides to it it doesn't look like
it
um let's let's implement it and
see utils timer let's close some of
these
so
for
okay uh where's that here it
is oh no that's the wrong
one that undo thing okay uh where's the
name space and oh there it is good
everything's good okay and do I need an
include for that
Chrono
oh that's going to put in spocky
space okay good um so yes let's just see
if this works the same
way and it seems
to so I guess it is in the same and that
divides it by a th000 so I guess we'll
yeah we'll we'll have this let's just
refactor this a little bit
because um HR clock so let's I don't
know
maybe I just
I'll just do
that that just looks
better
okay I don't know about how I I'm going
to leave it like this so I'm not going
to um actually get rid of the windows
timer just because I don't know the
performance implications of this yet and
I don't want to test it right now cuz
we're running out of time so I will do
this in the future but right now it's
just going to remain like this okay cool
so um but yeah so this will be turned
off though so just in case so now we
don't have any Windows um like
dependencies I'm pretty sure okay uh I
was going to say um where's our
texture apparently I'm not deleting
something my stream is telling me
something's wrong so the dip pointer
is n that's fine that's I don't I'm
pretty sure that doesn't need to get
delet did I'm sure it's not allocating
memory like uh do I have to free the dip
no cuz I am unloading it yeah so it is
yeah it's fine it's not allocating any
extra memory that isn't being freed by
this I don't think there are any memory
leaks we can find out
but we can load the we can find
out anyone want to find out if we've got
any memory leaks yes well in this image
thing this is going to be great um so
let's quickly introduce the the best
memory leak checking thing in the in the
in the world um let's shut that off real
quick and I did get rid of the other one
right
yeah this is our memory leag check um
we're going
to um cheuck
in
wait are there
warnings hang on a
minute oh that's yeah that's my bad
that's not that'll get that'll get
excluded by the compil though it doesn't
matter oh so many warnings oh now okay
that stuff we don't care okay cool um
yes so memory leak checking um this is
what I want to do and this is going to
be great so while
true let's go ahead and just call
um load
image uh file
name just test of PNG I
guess um
bite okay so just a quick example and
this is going to be terrible I should
probably sleep on this a little bit not
like literally sleep on it I mean make
the thread
sleep
okay so I probably do that by just
saying loaded IM because this will slow
things down a lot load loaded
image and I'll print the
width
height okay so if I'm not a if I don't
delete bite for example let's just open
task manager and go to Performance and
memory so if I
don't um delete it for example and I run
this bad things will happen let's just
do that and see what happens so it's
loading images
so let's
see uh this might not be the best way to
show it but if I go into
um processes
and then Sparky core 5.3 okay so you can
see that memory usage man that file is
Tiny can we find a we find something
more can we find something more damaging
um let's go
into uh Visual Studio project Sparky so
what we what do we have we had a little
8 by8 thing that's like 1 kilobyte LS no
is it even that no it's 156 bytes let's
let's fix that um destru
dve destructive so we'll open this with
paint on
that we'll uh increase the canvas size
to something a bit more
destructive and we'll gradient it so it
takes up a lot of space 71 kiloby this
is better than 156 bytes so if we're on
this now and You observe oh that's still
loing the other
one
destructive and you look at our
performance and you look at
memory you can just see that Trend there
I mean I didn't make it so destructive
but if you look at that you can just see
um Sparky just so it's using a gig of
memory right now Etc so the point is if
you see your memory going up like that
and you're testing something in a Loop
clearly there is a memory leak because
right now it's taking out one and a half
gab of memory and you can see that ever
since I started it my thing it's luckily
I've got a lot of memory but the point
is it shouldn't do that and then here
it's going to just fail so the point is
we shouldn't be using more than 2 gigs
of memory okay um and the reason that
crash by the way was because we're a 32
bit application but anyway we'll get
that's not important so if we go over
here and we do delete image what we
should see right is no actual problem
like as in if we see that it's still
going up that means that we're not
freeing a DI or we're doing something
incorrect so if we launch
this uh and we pay attention to this 1.7
megabytes it should not go above that
and it doesn't look like it is so we're
only using 1.7
megabytes yeah I'm just going to wait
for it a little bit but it doesn't look
like we're going to actually um use
anymore is there a way
to
details no that's not going to
help yeah so there's a memory you can
see it's not even like increasing at all
yeah so that's perfect that means there
are no memory leaks at all so there we
go that is a quick debugging tip um for
memory leaks but there you go so now
that we
are certain that everything is the
best um we can move on to the next
issue
okay um uff is in Vex already never
filled yes this is true as well in
vertex r. CPP we
um uh what I did was I had oh my
goodness this is so
annoying so there's the H there's the
CPP file so yeah so we had this uh
buffers
buffer um vector and uh it like never
actually did anything like we never
added because we stopped adding it cuz
we didn't need to so I guess I'll just
go and get rid of it I mean I probably
should just get rid of vertex R
completely um out of curiosity what
happens to the buffer that we submit
though we haven't done that in ages yeah
so what I'll do is I
guess I guess we should probably take
control of it and delete it at the end
so I will say buffers do pushback buffer
right that's what we kind of agreed on
I'm pretty
sure so the reason I'm doing that is
because it's going to store all the
memory addresses and it's going to at
the end just delete all of the buffers
okay um which I think will probably
um yes which will delete the open Jael
side of things as well okay so that's
good
so so the final issue
cannot reenable Shader to re to reenable
the Shader you would have to create the
Shader again which I believe is bad
what stealing it okay so this is someone
from the stream Jacob mango I remember
him um so to to reenable the Shader you
would have to recreate the Shader
again what what why is that because
we're tying shaders to layers and wa
what that doesn't make any sense no but
we're not are we no we're not tying
textures we might be tying shaders hang
on minute I'm confused to reenable the
Shader reenable what do you mean by
reenable do you mean
like like bind it like use program
because
that is does not require it to be
recreated I think he might be referring
to
um
I think you might be referring to um the
fact that these shaders get passed into
layers and then the
layer um deletes the
Shader which means that you can't use
the same
Shader yes well if he means that then um
that's all right because um we're not
going remember what probably not going
to have more than like 20 layers or
something and recreating them at you
know when you're loading it it's fine
like reloading the same Shader shaders
like it'll layers will have different
shaders anyway usually so I'm not
exactly
sure so hang on a
minute okay so Shader do enable which is
where we enable it all that does is
actually bind the Shader so that doesn't
do anything it doesn't recreate the
Shader or anything like that
this is the cre creation code in the
compilation which happens once when you
Lo the Shader so there is really no
issue
there so I'll
just oh look at this live updating
stuff I don't
I who knows he's watching the stream
though so he can probably just answer
this now oh this is just so long oh no
it's not it's about an hour and a half
oh wow it feels like it's been like
three
hours
okay oh I forgot to put the chat in the
Stream like I usually do
LS oh
well last time I think the the comments
on the videos were like you probably
shouldn't do this because it's
distracting so I guess I didn't do it
this time um get rid of
this I don't think we need
time no we don't compile it for release
as
well
okay release Mode still
works do I have a response yet
NOP yes release mode works and that
frame rate is good I was worried when it
said 3 and a half thous FPS I'm like
what okay cool
so there you
go now if we want to be really cool
while we're waiting for
this um we could check we could test out
our setting color code thing
so um Al but L's got all of our stuff do
we still have access to
them oh we just lay or added
them okay so we can't get the renderable
from the layer can we let's let's let's
let's do
that so STD Vector renderable
2D
reference get rendera
bles return m rendera
bles
const
o um
const okay
um
so let's just vary their colors
basically so for and IAL 0 I is less
than
um layer. get rendera
bles
our um what's wrong with
that what's that tire layer called it's
called layer
what oh const I wonder why highlights
layer is being wrong get Rand should
have been highlight it then I would have
been like okay okay so rs.
size i++ so we'll do RS
dot um sorry uh
RSI arrow set
color oh it takes this thing in so we'll
just go math math Spec 4 uh we'll set
we'll have int
cal0
so we'll say
um
c0
01 okay
and that was what it was before right
except obviously that was
random okay so that just turned
everything
off
um think we'll have like a red tint now
I think well yeah it'll get rid of the
other channels by doing that yeah great
Okay cool so it works but let's be even
more creative um let's go ahead and say
um
um so float time equals
0 time plus equal
0.01 uh we can probably just go yeah
01 now do we already have what oh
already did um
t Okay and then we'll say that this in
uh float
C is equal
to the sign oh do we not have that
function I thought maths math should
have it we're including maths aren't we
well this is
disgraceful that should include
math.
so s
of the time that should give us a value
between 0 and 1 so we'll need to say / 2
plus
wait plus.
five okay let's just check this
out
that is way too
fast and not what I wanted uh let's keep
this at
like one or
something add another zero here we
probably shouldn't yeah
whatever this is where a Time Delta
would come into
handy oh look at
that pretty cool it's a bit annoying
with the light actually
it's very annoying with the light let's
replicate what we had before actually
I've decided so none of and the problem
is it's going to affect the textured
Sprites as well as the non textured
Sprites okay let's set that to
zero um let's um that's fine let's turn
off the
lighting okay has this okay here we go
oh and then there this at the end what
exactly is going on
though share a
start
okay
done
so
if you guys have any questions uh leave
them in the comments below those I guess
we addressed those issues pretty well
now we've got this cool kind of
Animation thing going
on which I thought was pretty
cool to the FPS as well so yeah anyway
if you guys have any questions leave
them below if you guys enjoy this video
please do not forget to hit the like
button next episode we're going to do oh
I didn't plan anything out so next
episode's going to be the planning
episode in which we decide what we're
going to
see you guys next time
goodbye